so thank you
and hello everyone um yeah our names
have been introduced
we are running freddy um freddie maybe
you also say hello
hello i'll take the first part of the
talk and freddie will take the second
i'll quickly start to describe the
context in which
the the following work was created
freddie and i worked
in the middle of last year for a thing
called frontier development lab
this is a two-month so-called research
sprint
it's organized by various organizations
you see in
at the bottom um mainly basically it's
it's
by a company called trillium which do it
on behalf of
nasa and esa and they gather several
partners to assist with
things like processing yeah data
and all the other things i will come
back to it
over the course of the talk we were part
of the
challenge called earth science and the
basic question is
for for our um for for our project
where the rivers in the us are flowing
and um yeah we have created over this
course
several hydrology map um based on
satellite
data and based also on lidar data
like the aerial data
this was the team so it's not just
freddie and me
this is us as you see we um
yeah it was covered times so we were not
really in the water so we were all in
our rooms
the only water was the sweat because it
was a hot summer
um but our team consist consisted this
is
explained here better of four
researchers which are dolor and
thalohanes and me
and basically some support lead guys
mentors which are on the bottom freddie
gee
jonathan kevin and ignacio um
yeah we it was a it was a bit really of
a
wild ride due to time zones and all
these organizatorial parts
so generally it would have been based in
california but
three no many of us in fact
were based in europe while others were
in the us
so we had some organizatorial fun with
it
but now let's start with the topic so
here you see basically some some
historical context for what we did
so the current framework for the mapped
us stream network is based on mapping
campaigns which were mostly conducted in
the 60s and 70s
but also as you see here on the bottom
even earlier this was a lot of infield
work and um yeah it's over half a
century
ago and only based on very few
uh yeah quantitative images like it's
possible today
um from an ecological sociological
economic and regulatory standpoint more
information is needed on the time
varying characteristics and
categorization of streams in the network
you see here the different types of
perennial intermittent and ephemeral
which are related to the groundwater and
the
surface water and the waters challenge
is focused on using modern methods and
the range of geospatial data to refine
and update
the categorization and characterization
of streams at continental scales
[Music]
the challenge asks the questions can we
use machine learning
on the satellite observations in
combination with modern high resolution
terrain data
and other ancillary data to fortify the
sparse observations currently available
available via stream um
yeah here you see basically a connection
there is like
um streams which are not
not clearly visible due to their non
um due to their non permanence
um and yeah also
i wanted to say one thing there is no
slight for it
i wanted to cover this also i'm sorry to
skip back um
our work was basically sponsored here by
our team especially
there were multiple in this frontier
development land context
by the usgs which posed the challenge of
doing the stream mapping we had the
computational resources by google cloud
and a lot of the data not all of the
data
but a lot of the data was provided by
planet
so much also for naming the institutions
and not only the
the the persons
um so basically while um the
streamgage network is one of the densest
and most comprehensive of its kind in
the world
it still only represents point samples
at discrete locations so basically there
are these
gauges which collect data at certain
locations
and although this network covers major
streams across the u.s supporting
science disaster response planning and
policy guidance these
observations only over a small fraction
of the
u.s streams network so indeed 97
of the remaining streams you're shown in
red so this is a bit like these
ecological assumptions of how many
species there are
and and many not mapped at all have no
observed data on frequency
or flow or current state and have uh
functional categorizations that have not
been updated in over half a century
the amount of streams missing from the
current data set represents a huge
unknown volume of water whose eventual
assessment is required
for reliable drought and flood
prediction
in the next section we outline the data
and methods that we have used
to go from the satellite images to water
detection
so basically um we have uh
this a pro this approach i will go um
later more detail into what the vasanets
is
we we use basically this imagery with
high
temporal and spatial resolution um as
well as terrain data
and in in the end basically we can
create water probability maps which are
derived from the
from the imagery directly and based on
the terrain data
we can we can derive
the reaches which are basically the
based on
some um watershed and other algorithms
the uh yeah the the the real
flow accumulators and in the end uh we
have been
juggling with a couple of ways to
visualize uh the data and what is the
most uh
yeah the best to communicate in the end
we
found these
percent water per reach maps as you will
see later in this talk
as a very approachable form because in
the end
um this i will go into right now
and i haven't given this talk in half a
year and therefore
i didn't check yeah obviously the the
nice animation where these satellites
will be flying around
i won't be able to show because i just
yeah i just forgot how
how this was managed i don't know freddy
feel free to interject but i think it
it's not worth the effort right but
imagine a very nice video here with
these satellites moving and all
so this is basically what you see here
sorry
louder can you press play on the video
no
no it just it looks like a screenshot in
fact it doesn't
my browser also struggles with youtube
so so i don't even try
um i don't try so
let's talk a bit about uh yeah about the
the context from
coming from a remote sensing perspective
um this slide here
goes not into so much detail because it
was
also oftentimes used in front of jio
people but there are basically a couple
of developments in the last years
so the the very classic thing you see on
the left side um
it says landsat and sentinel 2. so these
constellations
get data at medium to high resolutions
between 10 and 30 meters
and they have very wide swaths of
hundreds of kilometers
and um yeah they serve a wide range of
ecological and overall scientific
applications
but the ground resolution is limited and
for this reason especially
and you see also you you get some images
per month
so the revisit rate of some of these
satellites is
of a single satellite is like 10 days 16
days
then there are constellations where the
revisit rate then gets lowered
but overall it's not the super highest
frequency and it's also not the super
highest resolution
the good thing with these data if you
are interested yourself to try around
they're generally free so if you google
for this stuff you will definitely find
some uh yeah some platforms where you
can use them
for our study now the nice thing is that
we were sponsored so well and that the
sponsors enabled us to use really
commercial data which is generally hard
to uh yeah how to uh how to use
and um on the the on the one crazy hand
is
the maxa data from the world view uh
from the worldview constellation and
basically
they are tasked so they they don't
generally
generate this certain set of with a
certain revisit
but they can be ordered and when they
are ordered they are there
and then they have resolutions of even
sometimes
below 0.5 meters we had a data set of
which we in the end sample 2.5 meters
so the use cases here are generally not
not a long-term
monitoring but it's more like you have a
specific target maybe an airport or
whatever also
obviously a lot of military applications
which which you then want to pinpoint
but then there's a very nice compromise
which is planet which was one of our
main sponsors
um there you just get and with just get
i mean
us because they were so nice to provide
us with data
you just get daily uh data with a three
meter pixel resolution
and even more so the data set we
received is a very
new processing product where they
where they merged it with other data
sets and it had
basically no artifacts which are
generally very uh common in remote
sensing like clouds cloud shadows
the atmospheric haze everything was
more or less gone which was very handy
and
it was just ai-ready data and we could
just start our experiments
obviously there's then some um there
obviously there's no magic happening and
the data must come from
somewhere i don't want to go into detail
and there were still limitations but
considering how
remote sensing generally works it was
very
very useful data set
[Music]
so i want to also talk a bit about this
uh as part of the study this is
screenshot from it we also created this
very
like a small click dummy thing to get a
better impression on on the data where
we then
could create these chips and just look
at it also to illustrate what we have at
hand and
where there might be some artifacts in
it
uh what you see here is basically uh
how many lines is it for yeah maybe even
a year
so our data set consisted of two years
of daily images over four i will show
later which
aois in the us
and what you basically see here is like
one image
a chip a very small chip from the very
big image um
just to see uh just to illustrate the
you know the um the seasonality
but you get one day one per day we
basically had images and as you see here
nicely
also with with a river in it that's how
the
the color spectrum develops over the
course of the year
the planet data i must say is rgb
plus infrared so what you see is
obviously just rgb
um but yeah it's daily data
how do they look for comparison um
so basically in the top left there's the
maxa it's 0.5
meter you see everything in it basically
at least it feels like um in the top
right there's sentinel 2
from the same date it's much too coarse
for tasks like mapping smaller rivers
planet data is obviously the compromise
um
and then also here to show it there's
the the lidar dm
that we had available which was based on
an aerial campaign but obviously
it's it's a one time sporadic
acquisition and not a
not in a repeat cycle
now let's go at least in some detail
into the into the neural network
structure that we used
so basically we had different input
sources we had the daily planet
acquisitions
then the we had the dm we did also very
many experiments we
basically took all the uh all the
different puzzle pieces and built our
networks and
yeah ran all the tests the way it is
generally done
and um now let me
i'm just wondering when the next slide
will appear here it is
um then we we had another standard unit
where we took the took the very high
resolution data of the maxa
and created also water probability maps
and in the in the bottom we did yeah the
modified unit which is basically
we have the multi-temporal steps and we
don't just throw in one image
we did test with throwing in an entire
batch like as a
stacked image but we also used then
variants where we basically did like a
three-dimensional convolutions to
to address the the temporal component
and these were the basically the
different networks we took
um especially into the vasonets i think
i will also come to come back in the in
the following slide
um so what is here now there's the
uh different aois that we had um
these aois are based on different basins
so
the basin is basically like a
uh yeah there's
there's at one point um and i'm sorry i
miss again
the the hydrological um gemini at one
point
there's where all the water flows out
obviously it gets aggregated from all
these points in this area
and what you see here colored in
different colors
are the other corresponding sub basins
we chose the
we chose these basins yeah based on
what was given to us with regards to
data but they are also
considered especially representative
here at least of the western u.s
they had different properties so with
regard to you know snowfall
etc plus obviously the data was in some
way pre-processed
basically some some study areas were
easier to handle
than others all yeah
they all have like different topographic
and climatic conditions that
is obvious and
some have more canopy canopy was also a
big challenge we had
i assume we will also see in later
slides again
like the canopy shadows were oftentimes
misclassified with water and also yeah
depending on the time of year topography
can also
create shadows etc so
one can discuss as much as one warns
about sampling strategies
especially also in the geosciences we
had two months time and we
had also people assist us with the
labeling from the usgs
so we in a way we we were a bit picky
but we
couldn't you know fulfill all the
pickiness um
but that's now in the end how it was um
we had of the different study sites um
certain locations annotated i think
i assume there will be let me quickly
skip
just to make sure ah yeah there will be
another slide who says the exact
labeling strategy but
um we basically have here some trained
test splits
where you see that we try obviously not
to
not to mix in and from direct
neighborhoods
get the same samples from testing and
training so
i would this or there is an argument to
be made that our accuracies are really
conservative estimates because
uh we didn't make uh it too easy in the
end
um but um yeah one can and we had also
discussions about um many of these
factors
and including obviously things you see
here
so um the polygons were labeled
on on images by the maxa satellite
the data was not perfectly geo-located
there were shifts in the data
i don't want to bore you and also don't
want to get too frustrated again
but nothing is ever perfect in data
science and compromises need to be made
we found good solutions we did some
shifts we did some other tricks i think
freddie could talk much more about it
than i could
but importantly and also maybe as a
recommendation because i see it in
segmentation tasks i've seen it not only
once and especially in the geosciences
it's always good to you know to to have
a
an anti-class so we are interested in
water but obviously
the best idea is to as well annotate
you know adjacent areas or similar areas
as non-water
this is basically what the what the usgs
guys also provided us with
despite the the earlier mentioned
uh yeah also discussions that were ahead
but basically that's really
really needed that there is like water
non-water
categorizations in order to to enable
the algorithm to make the distinction
and to to learn which class looks like
what
um yeah here we have
a lot of small patches
i need to quickly digest this slide
myself
so you see the different data sets the
the maxa
data set was just a single
it would not be right to say it's a
single point in time because it was
big study sites which were then also
collected over
different different dates so there's
some chaos in the data set
when one image is taken a month later
than the other etc
but for maxa there was basically one
image
at all um over all the study side one
one aggregated composite image
well for planet we had the um like i
mentioned earlier wall to wall coverage
of daily images
and then we had the lidar data which we
then also derived
different other um products from so from
the dems we also then had slope maps
and and other um
other derivatives i think in the end we
had like five layers
and derived from the elevation model um
and yeah here you basically see some of
the examples how they
uh how they look in the different data
sets the water non-water images
so in the end the the the the very
nicest
results or obviously it's
also a political issue um which one is
not the nicest it depends
on many on the exact research question
you might have
um but but to to get an overall
impression on the data
um we um
this slide we had before doesn't matter
i will directly skip to this because
this is more interesting anyway we saw
earlier already in the earlier talk
some similar like encoding decoding
structure we have here it's really based
on a unit overall
um where we yet we have different heads
um for a while we we also call this
the hydra because we have the uh we have
here the dm
going in which gets like due to the
different ground resolutions
um to make let me make one step back
we obviously take images from the same
extent geospatially
and then you have different resolutions
and when you have different resolutions
you need to take care of this because
then you have a different number of
pixels
at the edge so what you see here is
basically our way of
dealing with it which is that the dm
which had a higher resolution
than the planet data received one
let's say initial convolution and max
pooling etc
before then concatenating it with the
with the time series data
which in turn also received the 3d
convolutions
because yeah it's a time series data set
and in the end
we basically stacked it all and then we
ran it through
through a unit type architecture and in
the end
basically as you see on top
the water probability maps were created
then there is yeah there is not so much
more to say if
there are more questions later we'll be
happy to answer it
and i think also freddie can go into
more
detail if there are specific questions
and i will hand over to freddie now
anyway because we are
basically at half time roughly
awesome cheers ron uh do you mind if i
uh
share my screen instead because no i
think we do have a video
free time
[Music]
really there's some noise coming from
your microphone maybe when you hit
buttons on your laptop how about now
test
is that better now maybe you're using
your laptop microphone instead of the
headset
that's a good point let me fix that
[Music]
sounds like it yeah kind of hitting the
keyboard and the mic and now it's gone
yeah it's better
good excellent okay type something
okay i thought better now
[Music]
we still hear your type well that's
normal i guess uh
but i mean is it like distracting
i will uh i would just not try to wait
i will just not type let me show you my
it
sorry but i i guess i have not pressed
my pad i have to just gently press on it
um coco cool all right
okay so yeah we've seen this light
okay let's talk a little bit about the
metrics
and let me just keep track of time we
have
18 minutes left all right so um
how does a supervised machine learning
model learn
uh it does need some signal and
this is a like our study our model
is uh is what you call supervised
machine learning
and supervised machine learning means
that you
the machine learns from some ground
truth that
typically a user or some expert provides
ron talked a lot about types of uh
where's the data
and what are the labels and here i'm
kind of repeating the same story here
we've got let's say
top row we've got planet chip is
basically another word for a
patch sorry for the background noise my
dog is barking
um there's a middle row which is like
what would the corresponding model
output look like
in here it very much looks like a heat
map where each pixel
is like some value between zero one
saying this this pixel is likely to be
order or not
um and then on the bottom row you see
what like a visualizing a diff the
difference between
what the model predicts and what the
ground truth is so if there's a
misclassification
we would would signal it would signify
this with a
either a yellow color in case we're
talking about a
false positive or a brown or a red color
in case that's
this false negative uh so if it's purely
blue it means that's
a true positive so that's like a
correctly identified water
if it's brown if it's correctly
identified land so as you as you see
here one can something that's distinctly
is that the
the polygons that are from a land so
like the brown polygon
they tend to look kind of big and
squarish
and that's because when people were
drawing line polygons they had a lot of
land to draw them from
so if they were drawing river polygons
they have very narrow spaces to draw
them from and they have to be
quite precise when they're drawing the
the word polygons so
this is an example of sparse labeling
some people might consider it as a form
of weak labeling but
there's a lot of types of weight
labeling but let's not get into that but
this is a form of sparse labeling in the
sense that
you can't ask from a human being to
annotate the whole
uh you know hundreds of square
kilometers of symmetry
because uh land is easy but then we get
to the water you have to really find and
like delineate the borders of the river
very precisely so if you ask them to do
this
for thousands and thousands of miles of
rivers that's obviously like we don't
have enough
labor capacity to do this so what we can
do though
is we can ask an expert
to annotate key parts of a river network
that they consider hard enough because
then if they can do it with their human
eye
and their expert knowledge and their
labels are accurate
and the imagery is good then a computer
vision model can do it too
that's kind of the rule of thumb if you
can understand with your human eyes
then uh using the same data that
you expect the computer to use then you
can expect a computer to learn that too
assuming that you do this again and
again many times you have enough data to
do it
that's generally just in computer vision
right in supervised computer vision
now but how do you monitor all this
stuff like how do you
give a signal to the computer that did a
good job or not uh
you take each annotated polygon and then
you measure
how many you know what's the number of
pixels in it that's in the denominator
and then you may count how many pixels
you got correct that's in the numerator
so essentially that fraction represents
the fraction of the polygon that the
computer predicted correct
because each polygon has a number of
pixels in it and each pixel
has a class so so it's a systematic
experimentation problem
now that is one approach you can use and
that is a naive one
and i'll explain why it's a naive now
if you if you see the larger polygons
here the land ones are quite large
so if you put equal weight
to a land polygon as to a border polygon
then most of the pixels are going to be
on land polygons
so that means that in order for the
model to do a good job it needs to learn
to get the land polygons the line pixels
right
so there's going to be a slight bias a
slight preference towards getting
the the land pixels correctly uh
and because we have relatively fewer
river
pixels uh that's uh you know those are
kinda gonna be like
uh marginalized and uh uh the computer
is not gonna pay too much attention to
them
uh because in order to increase its
decreases loss
uh it will just uh put more emphasis on
on the land
pixels so in order to tackle this uh
what we did is that we took
every polygon we normalize it for its
size that's what you see in the lower
equation here uh essentially that matrix
represents
uh what what fraction
of the polygon the mark got right so
again
the top one uh a humidity must be top
one
it's measuring what fraction
of uh pixel does it got right but in the
lower one we're measuring what fraction
of the polygon got right
so essentially every instance every
polygon if you think of it as an
instance
uh now is being assessed on
on the merit of the of the the fraction
of this area
um so by using uh
i'm just gonna focus basically i'm just
gonna talk about all the models i'm
gonna talk about
are models that are trained with this
with this metric
that's what our losses and
all these diagrams i'm going to show you
are basically focusing on on this one
on the fraction of the book so the big
picture result is this one
where on the y-axis and the x-axis we
have the accuracy
polygon as i described and on the y-axis
we have a different
let's say let's say the same model the
same model being
we call it uh water nuts and
uh here is not a study where we were
trying to say okay well this is a
state-of-the-art model or we're trying
to say well this is this is
theoretically the best possible model
you could use what we say is
we're taking some box standard symmetric
segmentation model like a unit
and uh we're asking based on what
data can we solve this problem
uh how well can you solve this problem
so
uh we have three types of data sets here
one is a model that is trained on purely
maxi data does
a half a meter resolution very very you
know supreme resolution as you can get
in
the commercial satellite imagery work uh
and then you have
on the bottom you have a planet data
model sorry this is a bit misleading you
should actually say three meter not 0.5
meter
and that is a model train on three meter
per pixel resolution
and it's natural to expect the gap
because when you
when you train a model based on low
resolution
there's less features to learn from you
know i think that's a very intuitive
result right
but then what's more interesting is that
if you if you have a model that is
trained both on planet imagery and
complemented by lighter all these like
lighter by-products that aren't talked
about and the lighter information is
purely
you know the height of the bare earth
and the height of the vegetation
on top of the earth uh which comes at
one meter resolution
and by the way this lighter actually the
raw format is point clouds
uh so this kind of goes back to the
earlier talk and from the point clouds
there is a derivative product that gives
us a raster
so from the pine clouds they actually
derive the raster which is like
perpetually get like an estimate of the
of a height of either of the earth or
the vegetation
so you know we we could have also worked
with with point clouds but
the idea is that that would have
required a lot more computation
uh so we just get that byproduct readily
from uh
there's like standard procedures to turn
the point clouds into a raster
and if you train a model with this
fusion of products you get somewhere in
between which
which kind of makes sense because uh
it it basically says there are some
cases where
the lack of spatial resolution and
imagery uh
that's where the the lighter information
can act as a stand-in
and complement uh complement in in the
form of altimetric data like the shape
of the land
if you will this is basically just the
table but in
numbers form uh now i'm gonna show you
like a breakdown of the earlier shot
uh but now per aoi and this is quite
important
because some aos are harder than others
harder in what sense so in some
let's say uh think about the shape of
the land and
in some cases there are many hills
the cast shadows elongated shadows or
they're like very tall trees casting
shadows
uh there are also uh in some areas
there's more vegetation
uh this is what we call geodiversity
right so areas that are more geodiverse
they're also called i should say areas
that are less
universe um they are more optically
cooperative
so they're just easier to the eyes so to
speak right
south dakota is very easy to the eye uh
it's a very pretty length it's very flat
relatively flat
it doesn't have uh it's not a very
challenging
from a remote sensor perspective and
from a computer vision perspective
so uh what we see is that all models are
uh high high performing but you know
within the area
you can see also the same kind of
ordering the performance like max r is
the best one lighter
plus one is the second best one planet
is the third one uh
same kind of picture in upper colorado
but idaho is the one i was referring to
when i was speaking about geodiversity
and optically non-cooperative areas
where
especially the smallest streams have a
lot of vegetation around them
there are a lot of hilly areas casting
shadows
so as we see this especially affected
the models that are trained on planet
data now
of course the maxim model is also
suffering you know that's not immune to
this
geodiversity but if we start
decreasing the special resolution of our
input training data
we really see now the importance of
of the of spatial resolution
if you take that away then you have a
useless model
and even if you complement it with
lighter data it can only do you so
so good it can only help you so much
okay now i'm gonna do a further
breakdown
now for each aoi i'm going i'm showing
you on the x-axis i break down by
a characteristic width this is what i
mean by width
so let's take every body of water and
with a state-of-the-art virtual
uh arcgis ruler uh on
purple i'm gonna measure some sort of
like
characteristic width of the battery
water right and we do this for
every annotated body of water that we
have
and then we can do this breakdown so we
have
all these different bins let's say uh
for
streams that are go you know
above 100 meter wide all the way down to
the smallest
streams that you can put your feet
across
uh you know between one and two meters
so uh
because you know with very high
resolution imagery
is something you came up but you can
only map it with maxra data
successfully that's what this figure
shows
okay so as you see with the breakdown
you start to notice
as you go to streams that are thinner
and thinner and thinner you start to see
the performance degrade
uh the performance degrades more visibly
for models that are trained on
on planet and on planet data and
this is this is something that we expect
but more interestingly the
where the planet models start to degrade
is around the point where it's like you
know at
below 10 meters wide and that kind of
makes sense if you think about it
because
um anyone who has kind of like done any
signal processing
uh course or um
it's intuitive to say that if you want
to detect a change in an image
that change needs to manifest across two
pixels right
so this kind of goes to this you know
sampling classical sampling theory where
in order to detect an object of a
certainty frequency you need to sample
twice as frequently
uh of that frequency um so
that's what we see here is that uh if
you want to be able to detect rivers
that are uh five meters wide you need to
be
uh have a resolution that is at least
2.5 years
imagery and with planet imagery because
it's three meters per pixel
that means that uh it's it's it's it's
physically impossible to render any any
river that is smaller than six meters
wide
yeah so uh this is what we started to
see here like the the performance of any
planet the iraq model is
the grades however with maxillar uh
that is not a problem of course the the
picture is slightly different across
south dakota in idaho because this is
more corporate
optical cooperative and idaho is much
much less so
um okay so this is pretty much the same
table uh
i'm gonna skip this one because kind of
this kind of dives deep into the
classification performance
um of the polygons in average and
this is just basically to say that if
you're what
what how you know if you calibrate what
threshold you need to choose
in order to have this much recall and
this much precision so
this is a very typical analysis people
do when we talk about classification
i think you've seen this image in
summary basically we have two types of
models one is
trained on planet daily captures and
fused with
lighter data um and on the bottom we
have another model that is
trained purely on maxer imagery both of
them produce a heat map
a water probability map otherwise
which is always at half a meter per
pixel and you might ask why
would the planet-based model be a half
meter pixel
because even if it's a three meters
input that is because
our annotations come on half a meter per
pixel
so when people annotate these things
they're actually looking at maxwell
imagery and annotating so the annotation
is going to have the same resolution as
the native max area resolution
um okay so
just a quick comparison here this is
background always like a
kind of a famous i think it's like a
nature paper from 2016 where
it's considered like the golden standard
in water mapping
uh this is how well it does it we're
showing you here some google earth
engine image and
the owl model is kind of a comes out of
a
google earth engine and you can like use
it anyone can use it publicly to see
how well it maps rivers at certain
streams it's pretty bad
uh however our our model does does
pretty well at this line stream
so we beat the state of the art now um
i want to show you very quickly
illustratively uh
our whole pipeline in in a few slides so
pixel streams how do we go from pixel
based
predictions to reach level predictions
okay on one hand
in the beginning we have satellite
imagery coming in what you actually see
here is a false color rendering so that
means that
uh false color means that you know um
you get you get a number of bands in the
satellite and
you can you can decide what to map to
rgb the way the computer enters it so
the way what this shows is
really focuses on vegetation if it's red
there's a vegetation
you get this image and then the unit
gives you a water probability map
every pixel has a probability and this
is what what it thinks where water is
and on top of that we also have the
lighter information where every pixel's
height
this is actually coming from us it's an
input we don't actually predict this
so this is coming from the lighter which
is raw point cloud data
and what hydrologists typically do is
that they take lidar and they
derive flow lines so these white lines
are actually
flow accumulation lines there there's
like this standard algorithms where they
basically
do a kind of like a follow where does
the path of the
the steepest descent and then where
would water theoretically
flow to and where would gather and then
that's how they these white
lines are derived and then what they do
is that they chop these white lines
according to where they branch out and
then every
segment between branches between every
branching
is this is called a reach so everything
that is like of a particular
specific color is a rich unit so think
of it like a geo-referenced
unit uh and every unit has a collection
of pixels
now we can take the water probability
map that i told you earlier
uh of the unit and then for each reach
that i showed earlier we can say we can
do
sort of like a little mathematical
integration and say for every reach
how much water probability like how much
water
does the neural network predict for that
reach and this is what you see here
uh for every reach you see what is the
percent
uh that is covered of that reach that is
covered by water
i have half a minute left and i want to
close up with this beautiful video
of what if we do this for every daily
image
it all culminates to this this wonderful
video
and this is what we call a dynamic
hydrology map
um i'm just gonna let it play out for
about two years
uh it's only gonna take five seconds um
so uh in in short we have a we have a
byproduct of all
the basic the culmination of all this
data that shows us
based on a series of images daily
captures we can now
know what percent of each reach of each
part of a river
what percent of it is covered by water
so this thing of this is a time series a
geo reference time series
and now this as a tool is pretty
powerful because
it can now you can analyze this time
series and you can say where you can
expect water to be
at any time of the year you can do all
kinds of analysis you can say
oh this is where i expect the little
water in terms of drought this is where
i can expect a lot of water in terms of
floods
uh you know this is something that
deserves much much more analysis and
we created a tool that enables
hydrologists to do this kind of analysis
uh yeah i'm going to stop here because i
think we're just out of time and happy
to take any questions
thank you so much for ready and ron it's
time for questions
there was one coming from the chat from
jc
for planet data if the polygon contains
both water and non-water for one or two
m streams is the polygon annotated as
water
so i'm just trying to find the chat
can i stop sharing my screen for a
second sure
i also if the polygon contains both
port and non-water for two one or two
meter streams
it's the polygon annotated as water
um generally these are scales
so i don't have it visually in my head
spontaneously right now but
i would say that um on these scales it's
very hard
the the annotations were based on
streams that were generally
a bit bigger than uh than this but maybe
freddie
you have you have an opinion on it
well um if uh you wouldn't create such a
problem to begin with
that if a polygon turns out in
you know uh in in in in reality to
actually have both types of
uh things then it's about polygon like
if an expert would never give a polygon
that contains both things
just because like you you don't want to
confuse the the model
and it's like it's just like the way in
the way you collect data is just kind of
more logistically simpler
to say i'm i'm going to draw one polygon
but it's going to be one thing
like one type uh of course you can make
a composite polygon but like you know
this is more of a i guess called data
collection thing right but just for
simplicity here we would say
every polygon that we have in our
collection is is a one
class like we know for sure all its
pixels are of one class
in practice there might be small shifts
due to
some mis but but this yeah no no one
would sit down
the polygons need to be um per class
yeah and of course like there might be
also kind of like some errors like
sometimes they what happens is
uh and actually we had this in our case
like uh these annotations were collected
where people were looking at max or
imagery
but then when you take the annotations
and you try to apply them to planet
there might be some misregistration like
their
satellite imagery is not always
perfectly um
let's say uh orthorectified or
you know the the coordinate systems are
a little bit off
so some streams dry down for the year
and so give predictability of the
drought
that is the hypothesis is something that
we haven't
uh gone as far as studying
systematically
i mean this would be the topic of a like
a nature kind of level paper where we do
this for many many streams
uh around the united states to see if
there's actually any predictability
in uh in this uh in this time series
both for the sake of uh drought analysis
but offloads
but generally just it's also a matter of
not just like protecting
people but it's also water management
which is like a very precious resource
and it's something that you want to be
able to monitor at the near real-time
level
this is what the planet imagery affords
us like there's no other satellite out
there
not to advertise planets but there's
just no other constellation out there
that gives a daily capture across the
planet
at three meter resolution it's just
there's nothing like that
you know for a while won't be freddie
there's another one about
whether we solved the shadow casting i
don't know if after fdl there was
more stuff yeah there was going to be a
lot of programs yeah
we had a lot of ideas and few times one
would be to just include another class
shadow which would make things easier
potentially others
were more complex like including you
know the angle of the sun and seeing
where there might be shadows and uh yeah
we can do like physical modeling yeah we
can do some like uh
some kind of like permanent version of
uh ray tracing
to see well here you have the bare earth
you have a vegetation
just custom light and see where the
shadows cast
and yeah that's uh could do that but
actually maybe i was wondering maybe if
the people who are kind of
used to working with these like 3d
physical models and that do rendering
under the hood as well maybe they they
have some ideas
just a minor question i was wondering
how did you do your uh con
your neural network architecture
diagrams that you had in the slides
is that a particular tool for drawings
yeah it's a it's a
it's all it's all state-of-the-art
google slides
thank you it's just getting most
bang out of the back we have
uh there is a there is no github there's
a gitlab
private gitlab but uh it's just too
dirty to release it out to the public
so we didn't have enough time to clean
up the code uh
we we barely had time to get proper data
agreements to share the data
but we just got licensed to to release
the data at some point
we're going to release the data all i'm
going to say is that
there's going to be a proper effort to
create a code base and data set uh
after words 2.0 so we talked about
what is 1.0 we just got finding for a
follow-up
project to take care of all that stuff
that
we have problems with
can the slots of a talk be made
available of course yes of course
yeah actually oh yeah i forgot to
mention this so this is a preprint
called pickster streams if you just
google peaks to streams the way you sign
the slides
uh you'll find the archive paper which
also has a link to the video that i just
showed you
i'll just type it now the chat pics to
streams just google that you find the
paper
so where can i check if gitlab is
released if you may it's private you
can't
thank you for the link oh uh well
um after the end of the
second follow-up project so i would say
in around two months probably
that apple's also yeah yeah that's
pretty handy
yeah there's no like consensus of how
best to draw a neural network right
it's uh there's just so many other
all right i was wondering if you have
any tips for
somebody who wants to get started with
machine learning on earth observation
data any beginner's tips where do you
start
into to dive into this last topic
yeah i mean there's there's some
challenges out there there's things like
space net
space net is a great start like uh
there's now like iteration seven of
space net which is the using daily
not daily i think weekly no monthly
planet products
uh for uh change detection
of uh like footprints of buildings but
uh
yeah just like previous space nets uh
they were around uh
typical like language land cover
detection
uh classification uh object detection
these are very typical problems in earth
observation
i would say maybe counting them is a
slightly more exotic one
but the segmentation and object
detection are like kind of that but what
people mostly do
and time series is not so much of a hot
topic because
this is very hard to tease out a time
series
out of monthly captures unless you're
talking about
large-scale changes like if you're
talking about you know how
like uh the development of the city uh
then yeah monthly makes sense
but the daily captures
that you would need like for instance to
to map the intermittency of a stream
uh that's kind of like uh it's only
enabled by
by the other captures so i think what
we're going to see in the future is
this product has been released out in
the world uh all of a sudden mainly from
planet because like they want to show
that their products are useful
uh they're gonna release more and more
of this free data and then that will
enable people to do more interesting
stuff
um yeah there's this problem in the
satellite industry that
the main commercial companies that are
like hogging their data then
even though there's tons and tons of
like petabytes of data there that no one
is ever gonna buy
uh they don't release it out for some
reason uh
this this is this kind of culture but
plan is slowly changing that
freddy freddy please uh the the names
you mentioned just now at the beginning
could you
put them in the chat my english is not
native english uh space net so
space net is business seven is what you
wanna
like it's kind of like think of it like
gaggle kaggle for for us observation
are you kidding there is a kyle for
observation no way
okay so how it is i put it you put it in
the chat no
yes i just put it in the chat space
awesome thank you
so regarding mocks esa does a lot if you
just google for esa and mock
you will find things overall you will
find things if you look for earth
observation
mock um yeah some are a bit specific
um depends on what you want many don't
even have anything to do with machine
learning
but yeah there's quite some stuff
and yeah the the tools of the trade are
things like geopandas
raw stereo um
desk x-ray uh even though
the last two are not just specific to uh
observation but
they're very handy when we're talking
about very large imagery that doesn't
fit
in memory so if you want to read part of
the image
you don't want to necessarily load the
whole image in memory like you typically
do with imagenet
um so uh i don't know ron
i'm blanking obviously
yeah like raw stereo basically is like a
kind of like a
tidal wrapper i guess
yeah and there's like uh suites that
people use
in industry this arcgis is the one that
is
proprietary but there's an open source
version of it called qjs
pretty amazing that's pretty much
everything that arcgis does but
it's just the the ui looks
more like an open source project
if you know what i mean
the acronyms you said could you please
write them
it's hard for me to spell things you
know you see
with e with a with me
thank you thank you i'm sorry there is
another question
mine or question
someone asked how long oh yeah i said
two hours on
uh who had access to uh v hundred uh
gpus so just the
same with 300 uh was it 1 300 or
yeah yeah i want i want to say i want to
say uh
i want to say yeah i want to be 102
hours
yeah because we didn't have that many
annotation annotated polygons so
uh even though the whole of the imagery
that we have access to is a lot
uh we didn't make it only made sense to
use whatever was annotated
yeah for us the challenge would be the
inference not the training basically
[Music]
all right folks if there are no urgent
questions anymore let's call it the
night and let's
have a round of virtual applause for all
our speakers
and the great talks of tonight
thank you yeah
thank you thank you pretty nice
thanks for having us yes thank you all
thank you too
yeah yeah have a great day we hope to
see you all soon again
for we're doing this every two months
and um yeah stay healthy everyone
take care and have a good night take
care bye
bye bye
bye